.
RUSHERS UNILATERAL CEASE-FIRE
IN UKRAINE IS TEMPORARY.
TURKEY IS CALLING FOR A
PERMANENT END OF THE FIGHTING.
THE TURKISH PRESIDENT TOLD
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT THAT HE IS
READY TO BE A MEDIATOR AND
FACILITATOR FOR LASTING PEACE.
HE TOLD THE PRESIDENT THAT HE
NEEDS TO LAY DOWN ARMS AND COME
UP WITH A FAIR SOLUTION.
LET'S BRING IN ABRAHAM.
HE IS THE SPOKESPERSON IN QATAR
TO TURKEY'S PRESIDENT.
HE JOINS ME NOW FROM ISTANBUL.
IBRAHIM, GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK
ON THE SHOW.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
IT IS GOOD TO BE HERE.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU AS WELL.
>> LET'S TALK, IBRAHIM, ABOUT
THE CEASE-FIRE THAT HAS BEEN
COLD BY PRESIDENT PUTIN.
A CORRESPONDENT WAS TELLING US
THIS ABOUT 20 MINUTES OR SO AGO,
IT IS CLEARLY NOT WORKING.
I BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT
ERDOGAN HAS HAD CALLS FROM BOTH
SIDES.
WHAT IS THE THINKING IN THE
REACTION TO THIS UNILATERAL
CEASE-FIRE?
>> OUR PRESIDENT SPOKE TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY YESTERDAY.
I REPEATED THIS CALL FOR A
UNILATERAL CEASE FIRE.
ALSO A MUTUAL CEASE-FIRE.
THAT SHOULD BE EXTENDED.
NOT JUST 36 HOURS, BUT BEYOND
THAT.
THAT IS NOT WORKING AS YOU
POINTED OUT.
THAT SHOWS THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THOSE WARS TURNED INTO A
STALEMATE.
AS WE SEE IT, NEITHER SIDE IS
IN A POSITION TO HAVE A
DECISIVE INJURY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
WE ARE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
40 CEASE-FIRE IN THE
BATTLEFIELD AREAS.
ESPECIALLY AROUND THE NUCLEAR
PLANT.
THAT REMAINS A VERY MAJOR
SECURITY THREAT FOR EVERYONE.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE
ARE NO CLASHES, NO ACCIDENTS
WILL HAPPEN IN THIS AREA.
>> IBRAHIM, I READ THIS IN THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT READOUT.
CORRECT ME IF I AM WRONG.
PRESIDENT ERDOGAN HAD SUGGESTED
IN UNILATERAL CEASE FIRE.
WHY WOULD TURKEY GO FOR A
UNILATERAL CEASE FIRE?
WHAT IS THE THINKING?
>> BASICALLY, IT IS THE RUSSIAN
BOMBARDMENT THAT IS MAKING THIS
WAR CONTINUE TO.
IT IS MORE DIFFICULT FOR ANY
NEGOTIATIONS.
THE BATTLE ITSELF IS TAKING
PLACE ON UKRAINIAN SOIL.
THEREFORE, THE UKRAINIANS ARE
RIGHT TO BE VERY SUSPICIOUS OF
RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO OPT FOR
NEGOTIATIONS WITHOUT STOPPING
THE BOMBARDMENT.
THIS IS A UNILATERAL CEASE
FIRE.
IF RUSSIA STOPPED, THIS COULD
BE FOLLOWED BY UKRAINE.
THIS IS WHAT OUR PRESIDENT
OFFERED TO BOTH LEADERS
YESTERDAY.
WE CAN HAVE LOCALIZED
CEASE-FIRES.
PERHAPS THIS CAN TURN INTO SOME
KIND OF A NEGOTIATION
ENVIRONMENT.
NEGOTIATORS CAN COME TOGETHER
AGAIN.
WE ARE ADAMANT TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE THESE CALLS.
REALISTICALLY SPEAKING, THE
TAXES SUCH THAT NEITHER SIDE
SEEMS TO BE WILLING TO LAY DOWN
THEIR ARMS AND COME TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AT THIS
POINT.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS WE WILL SEE
MORE ESCALATION OF FIGHTING IN
UKRAINE.
>> IT IS A STARTING POINT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
YOU KNOW, SECRETARY OF STATE
LINCOLN, A MONTH AGO, HE
PREDICTED THAT THE RUSSIANS
WOULD PROPOSE A TEMPORARY
CEASE-FIRE.
THERE WAS A PHONY OFF-RAMP.
THERE WAS A WAY TO REST, REFIT,
REBOOT, AND ATTACK.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THIS
ASSESSMENT?
>> THERE'S UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE IS MUTUAL DISTRESS
AGAINST UKRAINIANS AND
RUSSIANS.
THOSE SUPPORT BOTH SIDES FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES.
WHAT IS THE ENDGAME HERE?
DO YOU WANT TO WAR TO CONTINUE?
ALL RIGHT, LET IT CONTINUE.
MORE DESTRUCTION, MORE LOSS FOR
EVERYONE.
THIS IS NO GOOD FOR ANYONE.
WE REALLY HAVE TO RAMP UP OUR
EFFORTS RUMBLE SIDES.
FROM THE RUSSIAN SIDE, FROM THE
UKRAINIAN SIDE, FROM THE
WESTERN BLOC.
THERE ARE COUNTRIES LIKE THE
U.S. AND OTHERS.
THEY TRY TO BRING THIS TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
THERE ARE CALLS FOR A DECISIVE
MILITARY VICTORY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD FOR EITHER SIDE.
THEY ARE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE.
ASIDE MAY ACHIEVE SOME TACTICAL
GOALS, BUT THEY WILL NOT SERVE
ANY STRATEGIC GOALS HERE,.
WHAT IS THE STRATEGIC GOAL?
THAT IS THE MAIN QUESTION.
ONE SIDE SAID IT IS THE
DISRUPTION OF RUSSIA.
OTHERS CAN MAKE OTHER CLAIMS.
WE HAD TO STOP THE BLEEDING
FIRST.
WE HAD AN ONGOING WAR THAT IS
ABOUT TO END THE FIRST YEAR IN
A MONTH OR SO.
THEREFORE, WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO CREATE IT IS AN ENVIRONMENT
IN WHICH THE TWO SIDES CAN COME
TOGETHER.
IF THERE IS A GROUND FOR THE
LEADERS TO COME TOGETHER WITH
ALL OF A NEGOTIATING TERMS ON
THE TABLE, AND UKRAINIANS DO
NEED TO SEE SOME CONCRETE
ACTION FROM THE RUSSIAN SIDE,
IT IS NOT ONLY A CEASE-FIRE,
BUT THEY ALSO WANT A PHASE PLAN
FOR THE WITHDRAWAL OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS FROM UKRAINIAN SOIL.
WE TALK ABOUT PRISONER
EXCHANGE.
WE TALK ABOUT SECURING THE
PLANT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE CONTINUATION
OF GRAIN DEALS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
TERMS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER KEY
ISSUES THAT WILL DEFINE THE
MAIN PARAMETERS OF THIS WAR
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE FOCUSING ON.
IF YOU LET THEM FOCUS ON IT AS
IT IS, I THINK THE 2023 WILL BE
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT OPTION FOR
UKRAINE.
UKRAINE HAS BEEN CARRYING THE
MAIN FRONT OF THIS WAR.
ALSO FOR THE WORLD ECONOMY.
FOR THE GRAIN SECURITY, FOOD
SECURITY.
THE IMF, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE
PREDICTED THE 2023 WILL BE A
TOUGHER YEAR THAN 2022.
THERE COULD BE A RECESSION FOR
THE ECONOMIES OF THE WORLD.
GIVEN ALL OF THAT, I THINK WE
HAVE TAKEN MORE REALISTIC LONG
TE